[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle effectivement virer
plongé de 46 ans il faut qu'aujourd'hui
je suis à la croisée des chemins un mot
de mon jeu s'est un peu j'ai eu mon
accident en a 23 ans et j'en ai 46
aujourd'hui
donc en fait c'est mon anniversaire et
donc fait mieux que en fait voilà j'ai
eu
j'ai eu cette période extraordinaire de
passer du temps avec des caméras
d'alarmé et je regrette rien et il
malgré tout ce qui m'est arrivé on vous
dit avec un seul bras en france c'est
pas c'est pas ça l'important
donc donc en fait j'ai ensuite j'avais
déjà vu battre de professionnels qui
était la musique j'étais cuisinier
gastronomique
donc j'ai fait pas mal de deux maisons
de belles maisons dans les palaces
cuisine et ensuite j'ai voulu faire mon
service militaire et puis m'engager dans
la marine pour aller voir un lieu
qu'entre espace est donc j'ai été voir
ailleurs et c'est chouette et donc
donc en fait après mon après mon
accident j'ai décidé de revenir en
france
et puis le reprendre les études alors
moi je ne vous écoute je n'étais pas
super fort j'étais plutôt celui qui
était au fond de la classe
ordinateur donc on a poussé pour me dire
un homme il faut qu' il faut que je
reprenne mes études c'est important
parce que aujourd'hui pour avoir un
niveau de régulation c'est assez
agréable pour pouvoir vivre normalement
il faut quand même avoir un petit bagage
donc j'ai repris les études et puis je
suis venu car cadre commercial donc
donc voilà alors moi mon but aujourd'hui
c'est c'est entre guillemets
désacraliser pan de l'handicap je
souhaiterais que voilà après mon speech
en fait que j'aimerais c'est que
visiteur handicap ça peut être sarkozy
est donc ça c'est mon alors il faut
savoir que l'handicap alors on va
beaucoup un but sur à leurs acteurs
warren
peu importe que pas de souci on a droit
de ne pas être d'accord ça c'est logique
mais en tout cas l handicap c'est une en
français sur cinq impacts et parlant du
cas c'est énorme
un français sur 5 12 millions de
français sont impactés de près ou de
loin par handicap
ces landes et en fait ça je la donne pas
à fond en fait ça ça ça vient d'une loi
or j monde j'ai fait mon anti sèche ses
larmes
donc c'est une haute idée qu'on se
constitue un handicap au sens de la
présente loi toute limitation d'activité
aux restrictions de son environnement
par une personne en raison d'une
altération substantielle durable et
définitif en fonction par rapport à aux
physiques sensorielles mentales painting
et chichi imaginer que 1,12 millions
personnes soit impactée par un handicap
donc ça veut dire temporaire ou
définitif cette loi elle a un spectre
énorme énorme énorme donc bon moi dans
ma vie je le dis plutôt bien un handicap
donc alors moi je je je vois mon
handicap
j'appelle ça 55 ans que ça vous fait un
match sympa et ça match on discute on
partage on échange et ça marche
donc ça ça me vaut donc effectivement
c'est pas toujours c'est pas toujours
évident d'approcher une personne
handicapée c'est normal c'est logique et
on comprenne fois pas faux pas en avoir
faut pas en avoir
c'est normal parce qu'en fait je viens
d'arriver les verrous est ce que vous
voyez où je ris comme j'aimerais que
physique
alors moi je cumule je suis désolé je
suis chauve gros et manchot sas et j'y
peux rien je m'en excuse de vie et donc
longtemps fait en fait c'est cet article
en fait si on fait un pas l'un vers
l'autre ça fonctionne mais ça fonctionne
pas que pour ce pôle handicap ça
fonctionne pour tous donc voilà ça c'est
à dire que ça vient de là alors donc que
moi
moi je je je fonctionne comme ça est en
fait en fait pour vous dire je le dis
tellement bien nantis quelques mois mais
mon histoire préférée c'est c'est pas de
bras voilà c'est ça on repérait j'adore
cette histoire et en plus mes collègues
l'a souvent donc on revient et donc et
puis un jour les filles a été peu de
cités et elles m'ont dit elles m'ont dit
mais papa tu dis ça mais tu as atteint
bras encore or tu as droit à la beauté
de la planète
alors là je peux vous dire j'étais
rassuré parce que moi le chocolat
j'adore donc ça ça ça marche
alors bien sûr vous vous doutez bien que
les personnes comme moi en personne
handicapée alors il plaît ils vivent pas
tous que mon affaire qu'elle évite pas
aussi bien handicapped moi et moi en
fait j'ai g j'ai la chance d'avoir été
élevé par des parents qui m'ont aimée et
avec une trajectoire stable dans mon
évolution quand j'étais jeune et donc ça
ça ça me donne
ça m'a donné deux cars étaient samedi
positif comme aujourd'hui
alors il faut ça quand ça m'est arrivé
au bout de trois mois je suis j'ai fait
comme jeu
je suis maintenant sûre que je me suis
dit soit soit je vois aussi qu'avec ma
ou soit je grimpe aux rideaux
vigile est engagée choisirais tu
donc j'ai choisi de vivre bien alors
bien sûr la vie d'une personne
handicapée ce n'est pas toujours facile
quand on est d'accord c'est pas c'est
pas troublant il ya aussi des
difficultés
mais j'ai fait de les mettre de côté et
de prendre que les avantages parce que
je dis avantage parce que parce que
c'est un item ça me donne une force une
force énorme énorme et donc
donc en fait le but le but de le but de
de ma profession c'est ça c'est vous
montrer que le deuxième set ça aussi
ensuite ensuite le travail le travail
c'est pas évident bien sûr que c'est pas
évident parce que quand on est une
personne au québec pour leur travail
alors le point c'est souvent ça se passe
bien que ça se passe mal et quand ça se
passe bien
en fait là les choses s'inversent et
sert que paris quand j'ai travaillé dans
une entreprise et le directeur qui veut
me voir lui donne moi monsieur raymond
je vais embaucher des gens comme vous et
je les dis oui beaucoup
intelligent comme moi et les gens qui
prennent des carottes râpées la cantine
comme moi alors une veine assurément
bien énorme je sais bien ce que voulait
dire mais ça ce sera comme ça faut le
post un profil et n'avoue vrai hélas à
match car là vous prenez la bonne
personne qui a des compétences et en
plus ces personnes handicapées alors là
c'est là qu'est ce donc
donc voilà elle adore ce directeur dit
un jour à l'idée c'est que j'ai mis une
europe
dans mon entreprise l'acheminement mais
personne n'apprend je vois personne est
bien évidemment c'est parce que les
personnes en fauteuil roulant
représentent une proportion de
population donc vous avez pense à
beaucoup un arriver c'est ça et je lui
dis pas que je vais détruire puis
maintenant parce que utilisèrent vous
allez voir et les personnes handicapées
qui sont pas forcément ceux des rouleaux
qui sont utilisés et puis vos salariés
ils vont avoir en avoir marre de prendre
l'escalier ils vont là où ils vont
utiliser
c'est comme ça quand je levais
d'entreprise
quand je suis embauché ou que je veux
pour mon poste dans un autre post je
regarde souvent je regarde souvent les
étoiles est la corde c'est pas la
première chose que vous regardez vous
mais mais moi je veux traiter puis je le
regarde jouer le distributeur de sable
parce que si jamais il y a deux c'est
compliqué comme ça
donc en fait je gmail hypothèse que si
possible si on peut mettre instructeur à
cause de sang est en fait devenu quoi
c'est le savon de gauche qui se vident
le plus savant de droite il vit jamais
voyez donc vous voyez ça sert aussi aux
personnes qui dans une personne valide
ou pas ça valide
voilà donc donc c'est important alors
moi bien sûr
moi ce que je peux pas faire
parce que ne pas faire je demande aux
gens donc je demande par exemple à faire
mon noeud de cravate temps en temps
quand j'arrive au travail des magistrats
bâle par exemple quand je fais mes la
clé là c'est moi je vais favelas ces
jeux peut pas donc je mets mes lacets de
chaussures et puis quand j'arrive au
travail eh ben je demande donc de le
faire mais là c'est alors ce qui se
passe régulièrement c'est que donc
gentiment super sympa ils me font mais
la cei ne feront les allah sait que la
première chaussure et puis après ils se
lavent et puis s'en vont alors je leur
dis non un bras et de pied donc après ça
va mieux après ils ont l'habitude et
après il reste le deuxième pied donc
voilà donc
donc voilà et c'est ce que je vais vous
dire aussi c'est que le truc c'est que
les personnes handicapées vous y êtes
pour rien je veux surtout enlever ce
mythe du fait que quand on est validée
qu'on a des personnes handicapées avec
nous en face de nous vous n'y êtes pour
rien ça y est c'est ce soit tranquille
où vous êtes pour rien bonjour vous êtes
pour rien et alors moi je ne suis pas je
suis pour rien lorsque vous avez vous
êtes pour rien parce que je suis donc
déjà là on parle d'égalité qui est par
contre donc ça rassurez vous un
tranquille on peut aborder cette
question sereinement en plus n'hésitez
pas à chambrer les personnes du cannet
parce qu'elles ont beaucoup d'humour
donc surtout faut pas hésiter
et puis si vous fait rembarrer sais pas
mais c'est pas grave et desquels faire
une personne capter qui est capable de
vous dire par l'emballage de carlos mata
très bien et passe aussi ça se passe
bien surtout n'hésitez pas à tendre la
main
ils vont me tendre la main que pas du
tout voilà ça c'est parfait donc
et puisque je voulais vous dire aussi
c'est que une personne handicapée
moi je moi je n'ai pas les ailes de
l'ange derrière gravé dans mon dos et
puis vidéo réel sur la tête
certaines lois je peux avoir vos
qualités et vos défauts certes je peux
être méchant comme vous je peux mentir
comme vous que je veux de super sympa
hyper intelligent
donc ça s'il n'ya pas trop là vous voyez
j'ai les mêmes sauf que la différence
c'est que une personne handicapée par
rapport à une personne valide c'est que
le matin quand vous partez de chez vous
vous mettrez votre vos amis vous mettiez
votre sac à dos vous allez à l'école à
agroparistech
et puis quand vous rentrez chez vous
vous avez bien travaillé vous posé le
sac
la personne handicapée post bac sac
c'est ça la différence entre vous et la
personne handicapée
ça c'est important sur le vous dire
aussi c'est que et on a vu un focus on a
eu un focus extraordinaire il ya quelque
temps c'est le film touche l'année on a
eu un focus extraordinaire par ce film
vingt-huit personnes ont vu des barjots
commun en vue deux fois et donc un truc
de dingue
on avait un focus ex ordinaire et merci
beaucoup parce que alors bien sûr la
personne qui est dans ce film de super
riches alors que la péniche
donc oui mais mais n'empêche que le fond
de l'histoire c'est pas ça et en fait on
moi j'ai adoré ce film et ça nous a
donné une image une image et de
l'autorité extraordinaire par rapport
aux personnes tuées est par contre parce
que je voulais finir par vous dire c'est
que dès que vous le pouvez n'oubliez pas
des boules prouvé qu'ils étaient aux
couleurs de revivre ses bras
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]